[Music]
[Music]
so there's this giant teddy bear that
the Internet's going crazy about because
apparently it has legs for days and it's
over six feet tall
normal teddy bears typically have
smaller legs in proportion to their body
so this baby is available still on
Amazon so we're gonna go ahead and buy
it and then we're gonna find out if this
bear is all typed up to be is it really
as weird in person how disproportionate
is this bear actually right now we're
gonna measure the Bears legs bears legs
measure 36 inches the Bears full height
looks like it's about 78 inches so a
little less than 50% of this bears body
is legs and that's why people are upset
this is the bear after he had a hard day
we're gonna see what the good people of
New York think of the weird Amazon bear
with a naturally long legs let's go can
I ask you about the bear this bear looks
out of control at all bear like this
with model thin legs deserves to be
shown off describe the bear for people
the bear is a life-sized bear
he's an eggshell color big fluffy pretty
excessive anything unusual about this
bear no he doesn't doesn't smell unusual
what's standing out to you he's
freakishly long legs
these legs hurt too they just gonna be
that long
I recognized this celebrity bear
straight away painted in a tweed because
I saw that lizard people thought the
bear as a Valentine's Day present and
then when it arrived were not very happy
but it looks like it's gonna eat me at
night hey turtle it follows leave it is
like I'm gonna kill you
you know the mozzarella string cheese
that's what those look like this teddy
bear is actually six and a half feet so
what do you think of that
so we're basically twins I mean as a
short person I find this offensive I
feel a little inadequate now yeah really
long and I feel like I would have to
drag him I took him heavy where that's
better
I mean it's freaking me out now it looks
like the bear is sitting down which is
terrifying no I think the Bears got some
nice legs so if anything you think these
legs should be a selling point for this
bear absolutely she would want the bear
this large my mom I took this home I'm
sure she would love it
also like what do you do with this like
a sexual experience there no holes yet I
would take this bathrobe walk with me if
you had someone staying at your house
you could like be like here's your beds
I feel like you would be a really good
trampoline it could be a dog bed even
this is the the teddy bear that you buy
one day before Valentine's Day because
you forgot to buy a gift in advance some
people are into weird stuff so yeah the
to each their own they're life-sized
there with extra long legs and then like
a winky face emoji the winky face is for
the sexual thing do you want to give the
teddy bear a hug you know why not really
I'll give a nice pat on the head down
how many people hugged it I would really
like to give the bear hug okay go ahead
do you like movies the strong silent
type like that you want to get out of
here that's what I thought